сільського вас подарунки і пити спадкоємство у
баварському sand вольфгангу
так тут завжди починається день антонову
майяра
йому всього двадцять три рок і у юного
фермера
60 курить і виріс на фермі та імені
дощових will з думаю про тещу лаштунків та
я стану фермерам топ то я фермер видно
народження альтернативи просто не було
алло я люблю свою роботу станемо руками
став овочів у було тримати атаку хочеться
на і берете худої про будки задоволений і
стабільніше
структур низинні hause мовна на суді
та антон ломаїв
зак вбивали не ціни на молоко нехай і
наколюється ще у сайту я добра мало
чар не платити по 40 центів за літр
все ще в 2 ci менше сам фермер
натягнули моя ж 1 у пливу о 1 годині
україні відкликання знову держави жито
антону то його бочкам нам а чого я там не
разу не всі 6 10 курок за мало б
продавати і дві сім'ї для лому р ац і
в мої будні не шукаю рівні до нього
спеціальні біогазові установки
фермер ви рубля я ти плід astrum таким
Адже вина закладіть дорога їхня
енергона цю і адже можна продавати
їх за нього і струн у міс цілу ми ріжу
брухту erp red bow біогазову установку 3
рок цьому
кл і ціни на молоко в підлогу до рекордно
низького рівня він нам і вирішив ще
одну гидкого джерело при будку не
заводити потуги ми не так заклади щось повз
вид ринку молока а зможемо опера
страхуватися ciara пеньком півночі
антон брухту rp шию своїй батьківщині їх тамія
обслуга вати
біогазову установку разом з під'їзним
дунаї ​​впали вільним блоком
обійшлася а 500 тисяч євро такі
покликання нині е трендом з ліз кому
державі наволочки фірми вдає
на аграрному міні фабрики
правда тенденція тя не така вже й
ново брухту та рудри моєї спільноти разом
з бочками які свого часу th пережив і
курс модернізації
то реформ кут осі interac американець
або наше покоління застало той момент
cool і сільській державі безодні
засовує ці частки більше техніки, адже
ручної роботи і вив будинку х нізації так
ви можете вбивстві накласти руди не в
жопу над 100 уроків ферму пасти
змішував і ти пару на ході владно
біогазова установка та куди іржава
субсидію ватами
20 руки забула давнім ria бачка зайчику
йому спочатку розпрощалася акули побуду
вали кренник а потім наш син навчишся
проти ти збив газу помри основу ожило
худий політичний вигадуй було створ
вони обидві to keep tile цієї зади
одним і ви вам це атрактором на фермі
в той же час наїдаєтеся а комп'ютер
dance найважливіших робочих інструментів
та автопарк денісівців рівара піцу за
зробить вії ім'я світу самому місяця
завдання все більше куль і х і у
менеджменті
робота з комп'ютером та складу не
електрони графіці це [ __ ] роботи в
кабінеті тепер більше не жуйку і
фізична братія куліс інтриг фонду
король вченого тимусу kind words lower
знаючи щоб сама свята цього розуміння
основи економіки пить спадкоємство йому вже
не образишся
вестига у майбутньому
ще важливі вішар цієї носа планувати
аджі інвестиції будуть значно більшими
кров фірма антона ломаєва традицій на
німецьких спадкоємство
століття виживаючи в умовах реструктуризації
hause перекусимо за хабарі
саму розвідку